Lara à
table pas à table je te
dis les mainses sont lavées oui
voir encore des nouilles bah oui c'est
pas des nouilles c'est des linguines
sais ce que ça veut dire linguine en
italien des petites
langues alle mange maman ellemi la
coupe tu sais comment il mange en Italie
h
heuxut ma princesse tu peux me lire une
histoire s'il te plaît bien sûr ma
puce
VI
un petit chaperon
rouge il était une fois une petite fille
la plus jolie qu'on a su voir sa mère en
était folle et on va pas lire soir elle
est un peu
NAS ah tiens le loup et les SEP
chevraux un jour dans un pays Lotin une
vieille chèvre qui avait se chevux et et
qui les aimait comme chaque mère aime
ses
enfants celle aussi elle est NACE ouais
ouis elle est complètement
NACE ah tiens voilà regarde la Princesse
au petit poid c'est bien
ça il était une fois un prince qui
voulait épouser une princesse mais une
vraie princesse il fit le tour de la
terre pour en trouver une mais il avait
toujours quelque chose qui clochait des
princesses il n'en manquaent pas mais
étaient-elle des vraies princesses
allez
all-toi
bien papa ouais je t'aime très
fort moi aussi je t'aime très
fort fait
maintenant oui
maman oui je l' à la danse arrête de
t'inquiéter comme ça ça va on se
débrouille très bien tous les deux ouis
j'ai prévenu la
maîtresse attends es en
voiture ok je t'embrassean
salut
ais je voulais dire que si tu voulais
cher ID vous Taz la tête je orang avec
Philippe et Julien voilà rappelle-nous
bye message
supprimé vous n'avez pas de nouveau
messages vous avez un message archivé
pour le consulter tapez
1 chérie c'est bon tu pe m'appeler
Madame la Directrice bon je peux pas te
parler parce que là je suis en voiture
et j'arrive ah oui couche pas tout de
suite je suis là dans un quart d'heure
je t'aime très fort je vous aime tous
les deux très
fort vous n'avez pas de nouveaux
messages vous avez un message archivé
pour le consulter tapez un chérie c'est
bon tu peux m'appeler Madame la
Directrice bon jeux pas te parler parce
que là je suis en voiture et j'arrive ah
oui couche pas là tout de suite je suis
là dans un quart d'heure je t'aime très
fort je vous aime tous les deux très
fort
y